Michael is there anything you need from
me I'd like to go back to bed yeah Joe
just get some rest to see you Monday
unless you're still sick um all right
we'll have a great long weekend I'll
probably be just
[Laughter]
sleep you enjoyed that didn't
you she is going to have kids and I'm
going to get married not necessarily in
that order and they going to live here
what
[Laughter]
I love you I love you Michael I love you
too what are you even talking about I
was just talking about I
farted are you kidding me I did oh my
God this is this is my place okay let's
go back to one hello Michael how are you
good how are you good to see sorry
there okay well why don't we just step
in what hey
he'd enjoy to be fired I don't think he
would tell him that I am far too
valuable to
you fire
who I I what who was he saying I can't
really make it
out fire quiet you you know what those
are
[Music]
grounds Michael
look at
[Music]
me hey Jim hey what's up hey um I know
it's last minute but I was
wondering
what hey
hey um I know it's last minute but I was
wondering if it would be no that was you
I was wondering if it would be
cool I didn't do
anything I was wondering if it would be
cool if I brought my oh my God wait it's
casual so I'm not really worried about
numbers or anything cool all right
thanks nobody even signed my birthday
poster probably because it doesn't even
look like me it's from last year
[Laughter]
no you're
worth so see I will end up having your
little butt in jail and what they will
do to you is nothing compared to what
I'll do to you before you get down there
you are not to be
ready he said I was
dull I'm
not he said I was
dull I am hoping to find whoever
committed this heinous
deed and I am
praying that I find this heinous
culprit I will pray to Thor
himself I'm not only hoping to find the
culprit of this heinous crime
[Laughter]
I am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime I am praying to
find the heinous
culprit I am not only hoping to find the
culprit of this heinous
crime I am praying to find
this I'm not only hoping to find the
culprit of this heinous crime I am
praying
[Laughter]
I am not only hoping to find the culprit
of this heinous crime I am praying to
find this heinous
culprit and I will pray
to I'm sorry I'm not
I'm okay I can do it I know you
can
excuse
me we try that
again call you back no it's about my
work situation and my living situation
and how they coales into one another
because I need a living situation in
order to do my job what
[Laughter]
please
please I'll make you
proud I make you
proud Stanley Howard Bob Vance Vance
Refrigeration Ryan Howard Bob Vance
Vance Refrigeration this my dad yeah hi
um when should we bring out the cake 1
or 1:30 one's good 130
I'm sorry are we boring you not
Phyllis I see the sales department are
down there they're in the engine room
and they are shoveling coal into the
furnace right I who saw the movie
Titanic they were very important in the
movie Titanic everyone in the engine
room drowned
okay your ass is on the line Mister so
is mine now I'm going to ask you again
what time did you go home last night um
six
six of
course something
funny cuz you know what millions of
people die every year from drug
use marijuana leads to crack which which
leads to Crystal Meth which leads to
death which leads
to I want to give you a nappy head
because you're
lesli well that's not your
character oh my God where is the
cletas if someone says next to the
vagina does that
mean on the
leg what does the female vagina look
like
sorry um my uncle told me it looked like
a sausage
casing I can't I can't work with
this it's too loud what oh we're we're
there
anyway I don't know why I did this I
don't either but
I that's clearly a different character
clearly old guy it's too loud I can't
hear you it's too loud we're almost
there even though this is a
[Music]
culdesac I missed my
left knock it off I'm connecting this no
that's not what you said when I came in
here you said that I was conducting the
interview now exactly how much pot did
you
smoke I want my baby backy I
myyyy I want myy
CH baby
back I want my baby back baby back baby
back I want my
Chili's baby back
ribs
Chili's Chili's baby back
ribs no wait out a second one
okay I look forward to drug
testing I used to get a runner's high
which is why now I
lift I'm
sorry that's
awesome what could I possibly pinch I
have no upper body St I look forward to
drug testing but urinating is not
something this is not a joke this is not
a
Carnival
Carn what it is nice job nice work
this says busiest be beaver I know it
says busiest no now you screwed that up
didn't you I guess we have to go back
don't we we're wasting a lot of tape
give me that okay Leon is a girl's
name you need to shut the
[Laughter]
up
yeah
I knew
it I go for
[Music]
Pony when you talk about it it seems
weird ah what the
hell hey camera be
camera hey set speeding hey s speeding
PE can you deal with this
P what are you
doing I love
you you don't call people
retards it's bad taste you call your
friends
retards that's it that's what I was
looking for here's your
headline Scranton Paper Company Dunder
Mifflin apologizes to valued client some
companies still know how business is
done it's more like the whole
article over the gums and through the
lips look out
stomach there we
go my uncle Harvey shro is a fudge
packer he works at the Hershey
factory now I know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what that is a risk
we have
to that is a
risk that is a risk that we have to no
no no I know what you're saying why do
you keep
going hey I know what you're thinking
won't that just
shed I know what you're thinking won't
that just shed more light on the penises
but that is a risk we need to take Pam
thank you Pam why don't you work with
palas and draw a picture of the
exposer I want it on my desk by the end
of the day or you will receive a full
disadulation what's
that I the way John cracks we had a
funeral for a
bird I'm pretty sure none of that's real
you're not
real
huh do we have any
muffins yeah take a longer pause before
you answer Pam I don't know if you like
country music but I was thinking maybe
one of these days God Bless
America would you please sign my company
directory I'm about people
okay
good something like that the hell is
that I want to see his penis I don't
mean to be crass but get prepared to get
wet
because wow there's no double meaning in
that it wasn't you couldn't even get
through it the most horrible thing I'm
so
sorry oh hey Kate how you holding up
pretty good Paul what's
up oh my gosh I have so much to tell you
yeah Tom Cruz and Katie Holmes they had
a baby and they named it Shiloh and Brad
Pit and Angelina they had a baby too and
they named it
Siri I think you have those mixed
up oh my
God either this chick is a dude or
Halper went got scared straight G lines
come on Kor pull it
together all right I'm the I'm the Candy
Man Santa's come early sure Santa Santa
would like to Bear Santa would like to
buy you a pair of panties little girl
Santa would
like so
gross I'm burp
[Laughter]
when it came out for soccer
practice I I pinched
him where did you pinch
him where would you like the Rice Krispy
treat Stars they Sugar Plum Fairy ones
su
Sugar Sugar Plum Fairy wands
sugar oh my God
Phyllis yogurt
container Phyllis yogurt
container
I poor Oscar now naturally he hopes he
can count on your discretion
indubitably you
man I don't know it seems a little shady
well that's all you can
eat you make very compelling
argument I'm sorry play
soccer okay
then so yall want to know what I was in
for no no hey where you busy what do you
need we're rolling Melissa Hi how are
you I thought somebody just said Mel so
you all want to know what I'm
[Laughter]
for unlocked
it this is
Toby this is
[Music]
Toby
[Applause]
okay you w
open
Jimbo last chance to
carpool s you want a car
poool car pool yep little car pool
together we're going go separately s h
what we car pull together
yeah I'm going
seing
no
[Laughter]
carpool we carpool together
yeah I'll meet you
there sabotage what are you saying are
you saying sandwich no I was saying that
before sorry are you okay I'm sorry it
made me laugh so hard to see him say it
sabotage
okay I got it now I got it sabotage what
are you
say I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry looking at American
Biomet I don't see that the minimum
CL hey
hey what's different about
you you look worse thank you
you got a
haircut talk me through an append
actimate step one disinfect step two
incision step three locate the source of
the infection step three tenderly remove
the appendix so is not sorry dude I f up
tce great it was perfect I didn't even
know so
funny I have to pull a U-turn because we
have been driving the wrong
way
God that's great Pam Beasley or like Pam
be you're
cute bis did
you did you break wind that wasn't me
okay that is
pungent I am not a bad guy I am a good
guy who runs over women with his car why
am I having such a hard time getting my
message
[Laughter]
across
what uh what are you doing here Hi how
are you hi I'm not in character yet
yeah I promise to give Authority back to
you when this crisis is
over do
it say it
hey turn your head
over
sorry do
it do it hey
Michael apparently this computer has
been programmed to feel human
emotions well that's not how I'm
programmed I'm sorry we only take
MasterCard or Diner's Club you take
Diner Club come on come on here we
go what are you doing
here wait you want to go today I can't
give him blood so wow good for you good
for you how often can you actually
donate blood is there a limit I don't I
thought there was well your body only
has a certain
amount can you hear me what what I can
hear you why are you calling me my
minutes don't roll over I have to use
them
today okay there's a press release that
Ryan would like you I can hardly hear
you
makush he's watching million dooll
baby he's going to try to kill
me uh I know I used to be a temper and
now I'm your boss and I understand how
that must be weird for you but
you I'm really sorry I broke that was
too
good well I'd do the scene but BJ's not
here and
resetting when I roll PJ go 20 minutes
to go time 20
seconds these are for you oh well how
thoughtful yes and one flower for
can we start from the
[Music]
beginning that is the best flower ever
okay so we're all leaving for the
hospital at 1:00 so free ENT fre I can
take
three we're leaving for the hospital at
1 Freedom
tree sorry let's just go through that
part okay we're leaving for the hospital
at 1 like a freedom tree I can
maybe you could just change the U into
an a then it would say lunch party Kevin
would it really be better if it said
lunch party oh hey lunch party it's
supposed to say launch Easy Billy party
nobody cares about
this damn I am trying to lose 5 lbs so I
brought in a fruit platter instead of
cake for my birthday but when Michael
saw it he said that's not cake and he
threw it into the trash so I was so mad
and upset that I dug it out of the trash
and I ate the entire thing in the wom's
bathroom do you know how hard it is to
eat sorry I'm sorry I'm not professional
enough to do this I
can't Michael oh hey Toby could you
close the door on your way
up hi Holly yeah hi I'm Paul I'm
Toby oh man Paul that's fantastic
okay goes hi
Paul I guess what surround sound means
is that right over here
CH two
speakers damn we have two
speakers what honey oh Jesus this is
terrible we'll never finish this episode
um check this out
Folds
the
wall sorry oh my
God okay Michael I might have someone
for you here she's really sweet and nice
you guys might actually get
along is she hot that was such a bad day
that was the worst take ever are you are
are are are you are are
you you got caught in your own little
trap didn't
you
[Laughter]
Dwight I have question was funny that
was fny that was like
fult
Dwight
[Laughter]
D
Pam what is wrong with me I'm so sorry
you're standing in your closet I walked
into this man who's standing in a
closet it was like ridiculous
looking I've actually done like six fun
runs for summer this charity
I asked for assorted Cutlery and I got
back spoons these are worthless I want
to understand what you're saying but
it's difficult for me when you use that
tone why do you have to say tone like
that she goes
tone I um want to understand what you're
saying but it's difficult for me to when
you use that
tone I want to understand what you're
saying but it's difficult for me when
you use that
tone Phyllis stop
it you hurt me I'm
sorry that's our writer if you don't
deal with things right away they only
get worse it's called
appeasement oh God that is so
disgusting I haven't eaten cottage
cheese in a long
time wow you have 75 cents so that means
you could get anything in the top
[Music]
row so that means you could get anything
in the top
row h
sorry Jen you're going to have to go
into another row what's this A Detonator
what you're holding a Detonator and then
don't push me down what
what what are you doing stop it stop
just stop it SP I'm trying to confuse
your sense of
direction
I am going to bang Holly she is cute and
helpful and she really seems it to me
okay I am so going to bang Holly she is
C I am so going to bang Holly she is
cute and
helpful don't come near
me don't do your sexy man dance you know
how I love it
Michael 5K means 5 km you put 5,000
miles on this flyer come
in hey oh my
God what no Michael stay you said come
in oh my God Doby yeah could you write
down the name of that Rehabilitation
Clinic you mention wow
yeah press
That's what does that even
say well hello
everybody
hello
everybody oh
man I tried to do some research once MOS
and I rented a movie about a Latina
wedding planner with a big fat
ass moose and I rented a movie about a
Latino wedding planner with a big fat
ass I tried to do some research once
no I know nothing about wedding planning
I tried to do some research once moose
and I rented a movie about a Latino
wedding planner with
enormous this is what we did last time
here we go will the someone's fault well
no it's it's not it's not anybody's
fault you know what let's just look at
the lines
and then we'll do the scene
again thank you you're
welcome you insane you are insane I know
you even get to any of our dialogue
that's
great Phyllis did I or did I not say
fruit you did say fruit and what is that
cake and what did I say
fruit sorry
is this is this funny to you
Phyllis she's nervous yeah well she
should be nervous because I'm about to
kick her
ass I'm going to walk in
again now we all think you're liar but
would a liar bring Minnie Mounds
[Laughter]
bars
I'm sorry bye
Stanley what did you call
me we're going to need a signal to bolt
out of there the slightest sign of
danger okay okay I'm not signal is lift
your lips let me
see no no no like
this oh no oh dude I'm so sorry
oh oh I'm so sorry dude
okay this is d
right
Phyllis come on oh Jesus are you all
right Phyllis are you all right are you
okay I'm
okay don't don't you even keep that in
there oh my
God
I think I'm going to need some my new
pants hey oh you broke it you broke it
oh
oh man this bit will never
work wow and this
copier
is working fine that's the original
well
could not have made a better
noise we are having an earthquake get it
on the
DVD rolling rolling on the earthquake on
the
earthquake so glad I you all the Train's
going through scren we just wanted to
say we're very sorry screw you guys
you're dead to me if you say screw you
one more time screw you beat for okay
guys I did the face you like if you say
screw you one more time screw you be
guys stop doing that it makes no sense
if you say screw you one more time screw
you beat hey guys just cool
it you knew you knew that one was bad
basically the Dynamics
of all right basically within the
workplace
[Laughter]
place
oh there's always a theme
idiot about the tickets I know I told
everybody
no
and then you put it on a wheel you spin
it and you make it into the cup and you
glaze it put in the Kiln and uh yeah I
bought that in the gift shop
though David Wallace's office hey there
gorgeous how you doing today I'm good
thank you how's it
hanging all right
listen my
name you know what things uh things I
guess aren't aren't so bad after
all
okay
you you either break off your engagement
with that singing buffoon apologize and
then date me or you can say goodbye to
this I
think Phyllis we gave you one hell of a
wedding shower it was a golden shower
Phyllis we all gave you a
gold we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave
you we all came in here and gave you you
a golden shower well where's my golden
show I'm going to try to get to bed by
eight eight yeah oh okay I love you
anyway I love you
too oh hello hi Jim you're you're so
close vicrum best salesman I ever met in
my life what's his last name I want to
say shishi poooo I know that's not it he
he worked at the tail marketing
place Shu laa I it's not it but he
worked at
that she Sha Sha dupu I know that's not
it but he worked at
that just I feel like some of these
directions to shrew Farms are a
little weird um I mean like 156 Paces
from the light red mailbox make a left
MH walk until you hear the
Beehive
and make a right if you are attacked by
territorial
Crow I had this is a really EAS here you
go anything else I can do thank you
you're
welcome what happened to four and three
Michael okay 2 minutes is too soon five
minutes and 2 minutes is a very big
difference hold it together right
[Laughter]
now I told you to war me 5 minutes what
happened to four and three because two
doesn't do us any good come here here
you got hold it together
okay this here
Plantation is running low on green BS um
you ain't got no money to pay the people
who sell us the sides and dirt men I
can't do this
Michael
[Laughter]
basically that was almost
impossible uh Aaron have you
seen Michael
oh oh hey there you
are hey take that again just for the
record I think you're overreacting a
little bit your mom's old enough to make
her own decisions oh well thanks Oscar I
was just wondering how would you feel if
Michael was sleeping with your mom my
mother's in a
wheelchair that was so sincere just for
the record reacting just a little
bit I'm sorry it's late my mother's in a
wheelchair do it if you're laughing Sor
Sor sorry I had to make a snap decision
Dwight no you you didn't you were
sitting there for an hour it was a lot
of snap
decisions you popped the trunk why did
you Michael cuz I this isn't my car it's
for the show the property you're looking
at is in great shape and the equipment
is 100% pristine are you looking the
conservative whoa whoa something major
happened wasn't my fault installed
poorly
okay I know Bob Vance white shw I work
next door just give him a call
call Bob Vance call Bob
Vance Bob just forget it Mr shrew are
you looking to preserve it as Munitions
plan just I'll call you
back oh my
God and we don't want them at our
wedding thinking Jim's being marched
down the aisle by my dad with a shotgun
wait there's not going to be a shotgun
no no shotgun that changes everything
can't back out now helper what are you
going to do about it there's no
shotgun you just did a classic gym face
at the end of that it was so
cute classic gym that was like gym
season
two I dusted off an
oldie you should see their
baby so I guess you recognize everybody
else you all right she's drunk
[Laughter]
drunk wow
rain rain I'm
sorry wow you coming
rain oh whoa
whoa Ellie I think we're out of fax
cover sheets
who shut
it yep still breathing Jim I said not
till she's older
okay just a few of the pranks we do here
we finally have a prank we have a prank
okay wait there it is uh it is rumored
that they will declare I can't I can't
see it um you don't know your
lines I lost what are you talking about
yes Michael what is so urgent David
guess who I'm dressed up sorry one more
time you should have like I do I have
the lines right in front of me I know
I've painted them on the inside of my
eyes like no no no don't do I
quirt I quirt quot shut up it's hard to
say your name I'm sorry Mich you don't
have to do this I can do
this what is wrong with
me oh God you said you would laugh
hey so Jim thought it would
right so Jim
thought yeah I'm happy because if Jim
and Pam
can't yeah I'm thrilled because if Jim
and Pam can't be Employee of the Month
nobody can that's real
fair oh that's the greatest thing I've
ever seen I just got out of the restroom
and it stinks the warehouse needs to go
okay wait how do you know it's the
warehouse who stunk up the bathroom
because they stink up the
bathroom no okay wait how do you know
it's a warehouse worker that dunk up the
bathroom they stink up the bathroom with
their smelly poo Jenna they're going to
turn on us come
on I can't
talk
Kevin will be eaten Pam will be taken
slave Andy will be made a warlord's
Jester and Meredith will do just fine
what can I
do your skull will
be let try
again what can I do your skull will be
made of soup
ball yeah what can I do your skull will
be made of soup bowl
cool
what's going on what can I
do your I'm sorry I'm sorry what can I
do your skull will be a soup bowl
cool all right it's hard to live this
way I don't know how you uh how you do
it man you got to just just not care
what people think about you at
all you learn baby you
learn
I don't know how you do it man I I can't
be so
cold you learn baby you'll
learn not
good I don't know how you do it I don't
know how you do it you can free me you
can live it
buddy you're not even enjoying it it's
not about the enjoyment it's
about I'm sorry it's he's not though
well this is all for Michael um sorry
okay this is our first time I know I
know two girl yeah oh yeah okay all
right all right rather than spend the
whole day in court we decided to settle
our dispute using a mediator it was one
of the options spelled out in our child
rearing contract alleged contract what
are you talking about the contract is
alleged you wrote the contract Dwight
you not was out of
date sorry I used to be a
cheater till I saw love
AC yeah what's your point here's my
point here's the church here's the
steeple open it up there's all the
people cheating on other people okay do
this do
[Laughter]
this
you knew knew exactly where that was
going of particular good day hello dght
shud Archie bar I'm sorry Archie
bar that's his name
[Laughter]
Dwight eat spicy foods what is the
opposite of that make spicy foods come
out of her okay nope no
eat spicy foods okay okay what is the
opposite of that take spicy foods come
out of her nope okay nope nope we're not
doing that
Pam okay so what is it eat spicy foods
and the opposite of that oh make spicy
food hey worker do you use the ladder or
the lift rft we use the rft
are you crying
Toby I don't see any strawberries I know
I saw them well maybe they ran away cuz
they were intimidated by
this this this is the babies learning
everything thing this is when it
imprints M you know not careful all of a
sudden the baby thinks that it's
refrigerator is its father is that what
happened to you I'll tell you what
happened to
me I tell you what happened to me I
didn't see my father for the first two
years of his life of his
life can't really explain what I'm
feeling but I like
[Music]
it I'm I'm good are you guys
good could that have been more dance
appropriate sort
of there we
go look on your face was so funny I mean
I I I'm feeling that it's it's very full
so I don't think she's been releasing at
all you're definitely feeling
that the baby should grab on to that I
think she will she'll be good so like a
c very funny over
there so just grab onto it and I squeeze
it that hard yeah yeah that hard yeah
really feel it it's getting repetitive I
think we got
[Laughter]
it look I can't legally watch this
unfold it comes dangerously close to
prostitution I want eye contact do you
understand how rare that is in nature
I'm not some farm
animal
hey hey out of curiosity do you have any
other characters oh I'm working on
Scranton
Strangler um I'm going to get you what
do you
think oh I'm working on a new one
Granton Strangler I'm going to kill
you oh I'm working on this grant
Strangler don't start laughing I'm
working I'm working on a new one strant
Strangler I'm kidding now you now you
with the Ling Kelly is even worse than
Daryl if you'd have told me this morning
that today I'd be creating a monster
capable of my own
destruction I'd have thought you were
referring to the bull we trying to
reanimate okay you know what J I am
taking you off this account for
unrelated re don't you smirk at
me okay okay you know what Jim get your
tongue in your
face okay you know what Jim I am taking
you off this account for unrelated
reasons he was really close to you we
really close he was really close just
let him flirt with her people meet each
other all sorts of way who are we to
stand in the way bam you know he's not
going to get anywhere and you know he's
going to blow our sail who okay cares
it's not that huge a sale the
Schwab bam you know he's not going to
get anywhere and you know he's going to
blow our sale who cares it's not that
huge a sale the Schwab guy do
us this here is a raon test kit okay
I'll be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these
out this is a raon test
kit please don't throw these
out see them all over the office
[Laughter]
[Music]
Mommy that's okay
random all right all right and wait for
it
hat
um I get I'm going to pick it up I'm
going to pick it up okay okay
and I gave myself a front
wedgie
okay keep on doing what you're doing
sorry can can we pick it up or no you
want to pick up or yeah let's just let's
pick up so he doesn't have to keep
resetting I think you have to admit you
flipped out a little bit I think you
should stop talking
now I just want she's still a little
sore are you sitting on your donut
on I think that well she just a little
sore still you have a your donut
H it's not like like I'm meeting anyone
on chat
roulette I was so Southern did you hear
it oh my goodness it's not like I'm
meeting anyone on chat roulette I do
declare red you want to take care of
this invoice okay copies and triplicate
right back to Mr Bernard
dog okay you know what I would't want
you to get tired walking around all
day
who is
it who is it
Michael
hi you say
hi he did he said
hi what's your blood type oh negative
universal donor universal donor
mhm
you have to have sex with a woman then
sex with a man and then just compare the
two preferably in the same night would
you consider nope taking that bullet for
me
no how do we figure this out well you
just have to sleep with a woman I can do
that then sleep with a man and then just
compare when you think about
both what are you free
sorry so I'll see you the wedding oh
yeah
okay okay bye
bye Jesus oh my
God stand right away let me give it a
whirl here no I really want to I want to
do it it's okay hello well that's great
paper was there all
along all right too tired to do this me
too then let's just not do it do you
have any idea the risk it w sorry you
did that was
funny I'm sorry just made me laugh I'mma
tell him you guys sexually harass my
sister sexually no judge is going to
believe
that okay all right
ho
um oh oh guys okay look we could we
could file complaints against you
that was good fine I'll just tell him
you guys sexually harass my
S you know we can just call it even move
on with our
lives hey
look we can all follow compl against
each
other let's try it again try again
no secret crying hasn't even opened the
tissue
box no secret
crying bo boy so we're going to go with
the most logical thing is that he
matured
overnight wait for it hold
on I can sit on your lap you can sit on
my lap all you want because I am a male
Santa and that is something that Phyllis
cannot do oh my God okay this is really
comfortable okay tell me what you want
little
boy I don't know I didn't know you were
going to ask me that what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know no
one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some
toys can can you give me some choices oh
my God Kevin please
sorry
Coppa squat here we
go
sorry COA squat I'm glad what would you
like for Christmas little
Kevin I don't
know I didn't know you were going to ask
me that well what did you think was
going to happen
here sorry clear we don't care so why
don't you just leave I would like to
stay this pertains to me I would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume I have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay all right see just the noise you
made when you stood up I
[Laughter]
could this guy doesn't just want to win
you know he wants to bury you he wants
to humiliate you and he wants to prove
to the world wait how long is this going
to take I'm like a quarter of the way
through
face hey if Sabre truly cared about a
long-term well-being they would set up
hand desanitizing stations hold up
what's a hand desanitizing station bowl
of dirt okay you
understand this is hor oh my God
that's a good impro okay you
understand the more we expose ourselves
to germs the
stronger a in the tale of Sweeney
Todd he get
shoot I forgot it from the top we go
right away hey you yeah give me our
biggest client on the phone
asmb um you can't do
[Applause]
that
what well let's keep
going that was I'm sorry I ruin
that are you
ready I C over
okay you don't really toss the Dome try
to destroy the old ways Gabe I will not
let you do
it we're going to go outside and I
guarantee you you can get out are you
okay how's the
camera Jesus
[Laughter]
Christ did you just SMS text message me
I just came from the museum where I saw
an
exhibit hey did you SMS text message me
I just came from the museum where
he Return to
Sender
clean up on all
five don't make me pre-fire you you
wouldn't
dare oh man and when I get promoted
you're full fired if you get promoted
ah don't make me pre-fire you you
wouldn't dare you're pre-fired and when
I'm promoted you're full fired if you're
promoted shoot
oh it's just like the old days I'm
working on an English character would
you mind get I'm it's called Reginald
Pua
and come on come on good
G sorry
mate I forgot me me snotted
crane I'm so sorry right okay this is no
good I'm not even a real actor let me
out do you want your life to be better
or worse or to say the same get out of
my
way
Danny look at
[Laughter]
me congrat
[Music]
wow
congrat that was good right so funny so
we don't
recycle we don't why have I been
separating trash into whites and
[Laughter]
colors uh could you please show them
into conference room B um I'll be right
with you the uh pharmaceutical meeting
should be able to move you know they
should be able to accommodate
us I thought he was going to show us in
the conference room B she took him with
him I thought she was talking to the
cameraman camera
lady so have you chosen a leader
yet so
[Laughter]
broad don't look at
me I still want to quit but if I quit
we'll all quit it'll be
[Music]
Anarchy
I still want to
quit but if I quit we'll all
quit I so want to quit but if I quit
we'll all quit
it'll does this even work that guy um
we're looking for him which way did he
go this way this way this
way that guy when he leades
which way did he go look for him we
looking for him he went that way I'm
sorry we're looking for him which way
did he go who knows this way this way
this way this way I don't know which
[Laughter]
way sorry
sorry
sorry sorry it's totally fine hey
Dwight the mall is corrupt mall is evil
they're appearances
okay Jim that is so
inappropriate you got to SEC the chat
absolutely get these done out out hello
hey here to talk about wolf is that cool
yes definitely as long as you're here to
tell me I'm a billionaire
you're on your way man on your
way
sorry oh no it's great I love working at
Dunder Mifflin Taliban
branch
ploop no it's great oh uh oh no it's
great hell going
bre we have three sex
or or heavy petting closets one
masturbation closet does anyone have a
problem with that yes gay closet five
that was five closet that's that that
wasn't the problem three heavy petting
closets one masturbation closet and one
gay closet absolutely I no problem
everybody happy with the glory hole what
well I heard about it holy fif closet we
will have a glory
[Laughter]
hole
guys I can't here take my
hand sorry sorry sorry Sor
Sor we actually love musical
theater I just noticed that you like in
the last one it's very
funny we actually love musical theater
the great thing about Ste
B oh he's hard to grab hang on
that's what she
said okay who can tell me that's s I'm
sorry did you
laugh Oscar bro br
yeah oh I should get the accident report
binder I've never used a gun V born
before what say what you're trying to
say we can't understand you ever we can
never what did you just say Toby Toby
get back in here right now I should go
get the action report find because
Toby's
having she go
hospital great group back there too uh
Holly and um
Mindy could think of her
name